ens un événement pour terminer ce
journal l'un des grands peintres de ce
siècle Baltus a accepté de recevoir une
équipe du 191 Baltus de son vraiom
Balthazar klosovski a été l'intime des
plus grandes figures de la peinture
contemporaine il vit aujourd'hui dans
les Alpes suisses et c'est là que l'on
rencontrer Richard tripau et Robin
tebou c'est dans ce chalet au 113
fenêtres que depuis 22 ans le comte
Balthazar klosovski de Rola dit Baltus
vie et travail une existence en
compagnie de son épouse latesse Setsuko
peintre elle aussi le maître des lieux
n'aime toujours pas parler de sa
peinture à ses visiteurs il préfère
évoquer la nature qu'il a sous les yeux
et qu'il l'a toujours inspiré lui qui
avoue que son œuvre est essentiellement
et profondément
religieuse
aujourd'hui Dieu a fait la nature et
quand il a fini il a trouvé que c'était
très
bien alors si Dieu trouvait très bien
son œuvre c'est qu'elle était vraiment
bien résolument opposé à toutes les
modes et les avant-gardes Baltus n'a
cessé de s'inspirer des grands peintres
du passé dans ses paysages et ses
portraits magistralement dessinés il n'a
jamais fait la moindre concession pour
lui peindre est un chemin pour pénétrer
le mystère du monde comme Mozart le fit
avec sa
musique si j'avais eu le génie de Mozard
j'aurais voulu être
exprimer le côté familier le côté
oui le côté familier quotidien qu'il a
dans
mes c'est dans ce bâtiment que Baltus
continue à travailler dans le plus grand
secret poursuivant son œuvre unique et
hors du temps il a toujours pint avec le
regard rivé en arrière sur les maîtres
du passé le quatroent voir avant mais ce
décalage est à mon avis un des grand
une des grandes forces de son de son
travail suscitant autant de fascination
que de critique l'œuvre de paltus est
sans doute l'une des plus importantes de
ce siècle l'œuvre d'un homme qui déteste
le mot artiste et préfère celui
d'artisan
oui si vous vous intéressez à ce peintre
et à son œuvre sachez qu'un livre
d'entretien vient d'être édité à la
bibliothèque des arts c'est la fin